all right and so let's go ahead and get
started and I've been told there's two
and mic runners in the back so if you
have anything to say please wait until
they get to you think you just pop up
your hand and they'll come over and so
this is the task intelligence breakout
and I didn't add the doing more with
less part so I'm not really sure what
that means but but basically it's about
and tasks is a way to sort of represent
what we do and tasks are obviously
extremely important and tasks are
defined as pieces of hope and work in
the range and scope writes from like
extremely small scale things like an
email for example all the way up to very
broad and large scale things like trying
to plan an event and tasks are extremely
important obviously they span kind of
everything that we do and task
intelligence is is largely about
technology and experiences to sort of
excite to understand and support the
completion of tasks right so and when
we're talking about task intelligence
and this afternoon that's kind of what
we are talking about you know in task
intelligence forms part of part of lots
of different applications ranging from
digital assistants productivity
applications and so on and I don't
expect and read all the text here that's
not the point
and it's more just to show the brights
of different things that we
and think about when we're talking about
task intelligence right so it ranges
from task extraction task understanding
with support tasks and progress over
time and also how do you evaluate
support for tasks as well and we've done
a few pieces of work in this area I just
wanted to draw your attention to them so
and we've looked at things like trying
to estimate how long a task will take
you and so based on the text of the task
is input can we predict the amount of
time that you may need to block to
complete that task right a sort of one
application there I've explored and
contextual information around tasks
tasks taxonomy there's been a bunch of
working tasks and in a lot of different
places as well obviously and and lately
we've been looking at and can we predict
when a task is completed right so and
can we infer from what you do after you
start the task or create a task come in
further the task has already been done
and tasks appear in a lot of different
Microsoft products as well these range
from Cortana to Outlook being a project
planner and to do either there you know
and these are just some examples that I
picked based on who we have here to
speak speak to us so we mean I guess the
point is the tasks are
everywhere and we do also have the
partnership with academia around tasks
as well and a couple of years ago we
started this venture called the Cortana
intelligence Institute which is a
targeted partnership we have with our
MIT where we sponsor research there
around tasks right so as I'm started a
couple of years ago it's going to
conclude in September October of this
year and and there the emphasis is
really on tracking tasks over time right
so can we predict how far into a task
and the person is and then we'll learn
more during the panel and speaking of
the panel and I'd like to introduce and
the panelists and I don't know if you
guys would like to but they come up and
sit here would that be I don't want to
sit there is up to you
can you set up here a bit good actually
yeah the decision right and so we have
five really fantastic panelists from a
range of different places all you know
each of them is going to speak to you in
a bit to sort of introduce themselves
and what they do and their backgrounds
and so on
if Florez an associate professor at RMIT
in Australia she's one of the key
partners in our and Cortana intelligence
Institute collaboration and Keith is a
general manager for Azure and developers
services Killens the principal p.m. and
to do and Shh reason circle p.m. and
Bing and wen Hao is a partner GPM on
project and planner so there's a broad
and range of expertise here and lots of
different microsoft products plus some
external perspective as well and just a
little bit about how we're going to
structure the rest of the time and so
we'll do a panelist round-robin reach
and panelists will speak for a little
bit of time about and their background
tasks as it pertains to that they will
have some discussion between the
panelists and Q&A with y'all so um we
should just kill it and go ahead and get
started I think I should probably go in
this order so Laura would you like to
start Thanks
yeah I don't think I'll be able to
finish ten minutes so an overwhelmed
user who is one of the puppies it wasn't
sorry now can you hear me all right okay
right so I mean on data with Microsoft
every day look at my phone with all
these notifications emails text chat and
appointment reminders I wish there's a
way to aggregate and help me to
prioritize them so this was one of the
real comments from our participants so
how many of you can identify yourself
with this great
so our meter now the question is if you
and I are going to learn more about
people's tasks and being able to
generate only notifications and
recommendations that are useful to users
how do we actually do this how do we
generate relevant timely and useful
tasks notification
and recommendation that would be really
helpful for for the users I think a lot
of you in this room have been working on
the search problems right so basically a
lot of the tasks in you know information
behavior trying to understand people
looking for information is almost
perhaps solve right so when you actually
say you know I want people trying to
search for something you always try to
infer the intent now the thing is this
information behavior these stairs are
very much complex because people looking
for information at different contexts
they might be going through different
apps what trying to while completing the
task and they might be doing this at a
comfort of their sofa at home and this
might be a personal task this might be
work tasks we don't know in fact I did
something I tried to do some comments on
my students work on my phone last night
in the hotel room and it looked like
this it was actually a work task
sometimes very hard to say whether this
is a personal or test well somebody
might be looking for information while
they're in a shopping mall and this
could be a mom who's got a task that I
need to find new shoes for my son before
the school start so that's at us and the
information behavior again is quite
different where you have an intent on
looking this and you know it may not be
a search activity but it's actually
going through you know different
comparison websites but somebody working
on a task could look like this too so
the context is you know this user might
be you know are sitting in their office
juggling three tasks on multiple devices
and in in front of him might be Azure
DevOps or maybe it could be a planner
while actually communicating with his
project teams on teams on the phone so
right now what has
look like in very complex and
understanding this is not an easy
challenge so I said to Ryan you're going
to be featured in my slide and there you
go so Ryan recently had an article in
ACM communication that says as a
community we need to invest in evolving
search interaction to support the often
underserved last mile in search
interaction and that is task completion
so it is very hard to to get there to
understand when do you know this
somebody is doing a certain task and
that chaos has completed now for me
understanding task behaviors has a lot
of facets to it first if you're trying
to develop a task assistant that can
automatically understand what tasks
users are doing right now where do you
start where do you get the signals from
you might have these you know your your
information in being in Microsoft you
got lots of information from your
productivity Suites you've got office
365 or the emails data and all that but
there's a lot more information beyond
that you know people asking you requests
but and as I said before you might be in
different places and how do you know if
somebody's progressing a certain task
and it's very important as well that
attach systems needs to celebrate when
you know help to celebrate a milestone
as achieve so a task completion now a
lot of my work even before I was working
with us understanding just the last two
years my research has been mainly on
context and behavior modeling so I'm
very much interested in understanding
user behaviors and how they relate to
multiple different contexts they might
be in and this is done through user
centric sensing so what I mean by user
centric sensing is basically you know
you know that IOT data and you know
everything is all sensed about our life
and smartphone smartphone has a lot of
sensors in them and basically can we
understand people's activities can we
understand what user drew and the
activities in there when they go about
their daily life
maybe it's a Saturday do they start by
dropping their kids in the childcare our
nursery before in school before getting
trying to get a car park in a train
station before committing to downtown
for work and then maybe they go through
meetings of the meetings of the meetings
and then they might have their money to
have a project fight crime meeting
somewhere else it may not be at that
workplace so try to understand these
physical movements and behaviors
mobility from mobility behaviors to
infer what looks like an you know user
mobility behaviors relating to toss but
in on top of that another source of
users and central sensing data are
social media data so we know for example
when people checking ins because every
morning I just have to grab my coffee
then I know that is part of you know
regular tasks and and these social media
data actually gives you semantics this
give you content and semantics into the
user behaviors now where do you start
with all this behavioral data it's very
important to always start by
understanding and recognizing context
because context characterize the
situation of a user and context itself
is a strong influence for users for
taking decisions so I just give you an
example when you get an incoming call
these days maybe this is rare right you
might be getting notifications about you
on your whatsapp or your team's now what
would user do with it this is very
important in order for us to understand
user behavior we need to know the
context is this person in a meeting if
I'm in a meeting will this user answer
the phone well it depends on the social
relationship it if it's my mom who calls
and I'm expecting her call because she's
looking after my kids then I might be
excusing myself from the meeting and I
have to leave but if it's incompletely
unknown calls I'm not actually ignored
and in in some of the actual call log
studies we've been Luke studying we look
at
behavioural very strong signals between
context and behaviors so even for
example if somebody had their boss
calling sometimes completely ignored so
these this was very important to
understand how context in what certain
context this uses will you know how will
you respond to all these notifications
and that's actually really largely
dependent on the context and we between
couple of years we've been studying
heterogeneous data sources to understand
all these different contexts and
behaviors now I want to emphasize again
that really context can reflect on
different behaviors of users when
whether or not they're doing a certain
task and the type of tasks that they do
so just giving you another example
now we what about you know indoor
behavior activities in a shopping mall
so this is completely different scenario
when people go to mall what do they do
what sort of ties they might do can I
ask you some questions some answers from
the audience eating good what else
shopping that's obvious hanging out
Hey okay what else anyone what meeting
friends yep they actually a lot of
instances meetings project meetings in
shopping malls and and apparently
they're also a lot there's also task of
caring like parents or carers with young
kids when they just want to shut off and
let the kids just run around at an
indoor playground and they can actually
then work on their email at least you
know so there there are a lot of cases
like this now so we did a project with
Westfield this was completed in 2017 it
was a large-scale
in the movement information behavior
tracking we had these Wi-Fi access locks
for more than one
we also have the content data so from
you so we also had access to the ISP
logs of more than hundred twenty
thousand anonymous users of the public
Wi-Fi it was a large mall in the city
Sydney so it has more than seven story
and what we found out is we actually
come up with these terms of cyber
physical social context these cyber
physical social context will largely
determine how we understand user
behaviors just give you an example here
so when somebody is in when somebody
wanting to buy and searching for who I
honest if you're not sure why this - so
those are - and the the context when the
issue the search queries are very
similar to the context of the shopping
mall so where they are at in the access
point so they're very close to the shoe
stores so this is of course not not not
surprising but the thing is when we
start mapping when we start moving
movement loads across floor so the the
darker colors showing the higher floors
you can see for example some strange
very quick movement I'm sorry I think
the arrow didn't point card correctly
but there are movements for example from
level 1 to level 5 directly why would
people move directly from level 5 from
level 1 right so if you haven't been to
Sydney level 5 is the the food court so
you've got the shortest path possible
from from the ground floor to level 5
and these the fiber content during this
is also very very specific to
work-related tasks so they might be
doing meetings there might be on their
productivity apps while they're sitting
in the food court so we can actually
recognize task
when we combine cyber physical and
social context social context means
they are at and therefore what we did
further was you know this public Wi-Fi
data are not annotated so it's very hard
to be able to validate anything so
that's what we then release a survey to
public Wi-Fi users we could actually
then analyze if they're cyber physical
social behaviors I you know using those
traits from cyber physical social
behaviors in their Wi-Fi locks can
reflect on the demographic data and
apparently they are very strongly
correlated so um what we use with this
data and we can then come up with some
kind of like try product recommendation
of where people will be interested in or
locations they might be interesting or
maybe some items or products they might
be interested in in in the mall now
another project I'd like to mention
before I mentioned the Cortana
intelligence Institute is we've also
done some work on a physical and social
sensing at work for workplace analytics
so we know that research on hot desking
hasn't been quite positive so but we
there's not much evidence about that so
what we did with with Eric was we
instrumented some of the workers
carrying around our mobile sensing app
and we also put some indoor sensors and
we collect also their project data so
the background data and project data and
we want to be able to see if if we can
infer how much a worker to concentrate
depending on multiple factors including
whether how many projects they have
right now whether they actually sit at
their preferred seat or you know they
just sit in a place where because
everyone else has taken his favorite
seat then you know I have to use an
existing other seat or and there's a lot
of other data we collect including CEO
to act which means air quality and we've
done some analysis where apparently
concentration the ability the perceived
concentration reported by the user
really has a strong correlation with the
Nam
of meetings when there are no more
meetings of the the less they can
concentrate and apparently although the
reported concentration they actually say
well co2 or air quality and temperature
doesn't have an impact on my
concentration in fact when we look at
the data it does have any he has a very
strong relationship and when they
actually sit at the preferred zones they
actually also have a better productivity
pursue productivity so here I'm not
going to talk more about that now when
you look at these two data sets that
we've been talking about the mall and
this workplace is so very specific to
that those two buildings now the
challenge is how how do we recognize
task behaviors in daily life from people
that can work at multiple places not
just Microsoft not just universities but
maybe people who are working in
marketing agencies people who are
working in all kind of we're all kind of
professional roles really so there's a
really challenge challenging thing
another challenge is there's no data set
that will give you there's a lot of data
on you know you've been collecting a lot
of data on online activities for example
and email activities project activities
but you know and also there's another
group on ubiquitous computing I come
from you be competing research field
collecting a lot of mobile sensing data
but we don't have the task annotations
and this is what we need so how do we
construct such a data set for test
intelligence and this is why the RMIT
court I mean my career so far MIT
Cortana until I just Institute was
launched so Ryan just a correction it
was launched last year February 2018 so
it wasn't that long ago so I is this is
just a just a bit more than a year ago
and the the main aim of CI I was to
build a bench my data set for task
behaviors now
how do we do that first we need to
collect rich annotations of what people
do and we do that through sprint
sampling and end of day survey so we
collecting title notations it states and
the progress of every task and the
activities the sub activities of those
tasks and while we do that we
continuously lock the cyber physical and
social signals so again what is the
cyber physical social so this cyber
signals means the online activities
including the browse web domain app
category app usage time the physical
signals including movement and social
including basically calendar information
whether somebody's busy in a meeting or
and all that now what makes it harder
though the existing categorization of
tasks are very broad according to
American time use survey so the American
time you serve it has these attacks on
the US personal tasks work related to
social exercise entertainment caring and
civil obligations but work related tasks
has no subcategory well everything else
has subcategory so this is why then we
before we cited the logging we send out
a survey to more than 400 participants
in english-speaking countries so that
includes us and the outcome is a new
work work tasks are so taxonomy so this
was publishing in cheer so the work the
sub category and we call this as micro
tasks include communication
documentation planning and so on you can
you can see the list there now
now that we've we've come up with this
way of annotating tasks we we then
collect the data from a range of
professionals and non-professionals so
non professional mean students and this
is what make that makes a day unique as
well because a lot of data has been
collected mainly on students so and what
make it challenging is we need to
collect data we challenging ourselves
that we want to collect data over four
weeks so we can then start observing
long-term behaviors on longer longer
term behaviors on tasks and of course to
get someone on a manager level a
business owner to be able to be involved
which and then we actually have a weekly
meeting every week to actually make sure
the the data that we collecting the
annotation of collecting actually makes
sense so there's a lot of work on on
that part as well and weekly meetings so
we actually pay the participants you can
I'll tell you more later about it if you
interested how much we have to pay eight
participants to keep them engage over
four weeks so what do we get in fact
before I go there we did this over seven
batches and we've just completed the
data question last month so because it
these every time we do this because of
the weekly meetings we can only onboard
ten maximum because of the number of
people that are available to do the
interview every week so we can we've we
did this over 12 months data collection
and the behavior locks we've got more
than 200 now sorry nearly 200 row
features I need to get it correct so
nearly 200 refused including calendar
events movement data so we even get the
transport hit map so we're where they
are likely to depart even potentially we
can learn their transport modes
important locations in this person's
life
cyber data including background and
foreground app and mobile also on
desktop if they install the the
application on their desktop or laptop
is their work allows for it then we'll
be able to no less than somebody's on
Microsoft work or if somebody's on
Project will be able to get that and if
they also install the the browser
plug-in then we'll also be able to
collect the website now along with that
there's a lot of sensor data channels
including facility Wi-Fi cell tower and
all that so and the report the test data
there are some partial snapshot of that
for example there
so I'm gonna report that to us let's say
I'm affected investigating on email this
project a or I'm looking compliance
governance so you've got a lot of we
haven't done any NLP at all on this data
and all some it's pretty pretty noisy so
so and along with that people actually
report whether they think each of these
tasks require cyber or physical or
social context and we we like we did
some initial analysis on the data as
well
we found that median saturation is just
about a half an hour except personal
tasks they're they're much shorter
work-related task participants only the
work once you can see it across the
users work-related tasks has different
duration so that means every and these
are people from completely different
work domains so that means work tasks
are very personalized you cannot really
learn one model and train it across
other users especially if they're from
different disciplines or they've from
different industry and when we look at
the long tail a lot of these long tail
consists of the micro tasks related
caring personal social exercise and
entertainment and when we look at the
reported cyber-physical social context
that are required during tasks we found
that a lot of these especially
work-related tasks actually require
cyber physical social context so you can
see the dark blue ones are basically the
number of tasks where they think
requiring cyber physical social context
and and if you look at this for example
a lot of the work done here for example
Microsoft our cyber only if you look at
the aggregate of this that would be just
representing maybe a quarter of the
tasks so that's why it's very important
to to be able to collect and understand
behavior from different signals because
I don't have much more time I'll skip
this some of the initial analysis that
we did
basically it also shows that when we
combine these signals cyber-physical
social we can identify tasks better
still a long long way to go because we
still have misclassified tasks I don't
have time to talk about that we also
look at feature importance analysis
across different tasks some initial
insights are for example we could look
at communication related tasks really
can be some of the important features
including social signals and this is an
you know common sense of course some of
these like when you move you know you
can actually recognize travel ties and
all those things there are more detailed
findings to come and happy to share more
as well in the workshop this Friday and
there's still a lot more to be done so
we need to recognize tasks in 10
recognized tasks progress from this
long-term tasks and how can you even
analyze team based toss sorry thank you
[Applause]
hello my name is Keith Ballinger I'm the
general manager for Microsoft's
developer services organization I won't
use slides all this talk very briefly so
we can get through the other
participants as well generally speaking
in developer services we focus less on
the individual tasks and work that a
developer is doing while coding and
creating a feature those kinds of things
it's important but it's generally
important because we're trying to find
ways to build tools and technology to
automate what we're trying to do and
that kind of goes to the heart of what
we're trying to do with developer
services which is essentially for both
Microsoft's own engineers and for all of
the what we call third-party engineers
in the world we're trying to build those
services that make them more successful
and more productive what that means
though in practice is it's far less
about helping someone's type faster so
to speak in general developers
especially professionals who've been
added a while find ways to kind of
create context create flow
you know they lock themselves in the
room they do the things necessary to
kind of hammer out a feature so one of
the areas that we focus a lot on is what
does it mean for a team to complete work
and in particular if you think of a task
for instance as a particular bug that
needs to be fixed or a feature that you
want to ship in your service or in a
mobile application or even the launch of
a new product a team needs to work
together to do that and there's a lot of
different techniques that you can look
at in order to make a team more
effective and in general as you notice
one of the products I owned is called
Azure DevOps the kind of the DevOps
world is a set of tools technology is
really like a kind of a philosophy of
process around how you can shape a team
to do certain things and how you can get
them to work more closely together a lot
of that comes from you know various
management science from the 20th century
so for instance Elihu gold Bratz Theory
of Constraints
is around taking any particular system
and he was looking at manufacturing
systems in the 70s and looking at you
don't optimize you optimizing any
particular step in a manufacturing
process is generally useless and it's
you're just creating waste and you're
just piling up inventory which was a is
a real deal killer in the manufacturing
world unless you're optimizing the part
of the process the task that is actually
a bottleneck and the Theory of
Constraints is completely focused on
this idea of reducing waste and reducing
inventory in order to by optimizing
finding your biggest bottleneck and
fixing that and for whatever reason when
explained it sounds quite normal but if
you look at how software engineers in
particular work in teams this can still
be a problem where a developer may want
to optimize a part of their process or a
team they want to optimize a part of
their process but and they're missing
the forest for the trees in that again
you can code as fast as you want you
know I could put all developers through
typing school and make sure they all can
type 100 words a minute it doesn't
really matter whether you type 100 words
a minute or you type one word a minute
as a developer that's not where the
bottleneck is and so that's kind of Li
to the other area of interest with me
and my team is well what does it mean to
reduce waste right using that
manufacturing trim what does it mean to
have you know piled up inventory and in
the world of services today and apps and
things like that
what it generally comes down to is the
fact that how quickly you ship something
doesn't matter how quickly you fix a bug
for a user or ship a new feature doesn't
matter if no one's using it and if you
actually haven't solved the customers
problem so a lot of our focus has been
around how do we spend more time
understanding what the actual customer
problem is and what the value that the
customer needs to have is and then once
we know that we know we can ship the
right thing and this becomes very
interesting when you think about the
idea of tasks in assistance that help
you with tasks in my world of
development there are certainly some
great examples of where we can help
developers in doing what they're doing
on a day to day basis in particular I
think there's a lot to do around say for
instance code review and helping people
make and more intelligent decisions
around the code they just wrote and is
it really good and there's certainly a
lot of automation we can do if you look
back 20 years ago when I was a developer
20 years ago there were a production
systems I was working on where I would
literally take a floppy disk and I would
take it from my computer to another
server somewhere and then I would load
new code in that world's gone today
people everything is automated and for
the most part developers are already
really good at this they're good at
automating things that are drudgery that
they that are very repetitive in fact
you could really look at the entire in
just software industry as just a
progression of automating more and more
things that are otherwise manual tasks
that people would have to do which
leaves us to this place where it really
becomes well if you want to be
innovative and you want to be a a
company or a team that is outperforming
your competitors you have to kind of
focus much more on rethinking what the
task is and the task goes away from
being here's a feature that I need to
code and then deploy to a server to
being I have a customer problem that
aligns with what my business is trying
to solve
and therefore trying to break through
with what that means and in those cases
often times the real bottleneck and the
world the place where the most help is
needed is in reducing the risk and
uncertainty of is the code you're about
to write actually useful to anybody Wow
and so with that I will pass it off to
the next person Thanks hi I'm Caitlin
Hart I work on the Microsoft to do team
more generally we have the ecosystem of
tasks lists and reminders at Microsoft
it might be outlook tasks where Cortana
reminders are stored it's it's an
experience that we're we're pretty proud
of but we're continuing to improve
we've been looking a lot lately at and
and by the way excellent selection of
panelists cuz these are all like I'm
just so thrilled at the topics that
we're talking about today these are all
the things that keep me up at night
we're trying to help people to do more
and to be able to achieve more and I
guess I would say more the latter not do
more tasks not just get through your
to-do list but actually to be able to
end the day feeling accomplished and
that requires a lot it requires first of
all you to have a sense for everything
that you have to do a collection of
everything
we aim to to serve that by having a
collection in in the ecosystem that we
support all of your tasks that you
capture an explicit to-do list show of
hands how many keep a to-do list in a
digital app yeah pretty common piece of
paper yeah you're not alone it's it's
the tests that we capture explicitly
people emailing themselves tasks
emailing themselves reminders a lot of
tasks come in through communication and
often tasks are just following up on
communication channels email is not a
great to-do list it's very reactive
you just wind up playing whack-a-mole
with incoming things all day and it's
even worse now that we have more chat
channels and communication becoming
fragmented means I have to follow up on
communication tasks from everywhere but
that's not the end of it I have to save
other things that I need to follow up on
I have documents that I need to finish
or big projects or goals and I need to
capture those somehow so I have to get a
sense for everything that I need to
collect we also have tasks that are
assigned right assigned through projects
through any sort of team task tracking
experience either digitally or
you know the post-it notes that you have
for tracking what assignments you have
out of your team meeting this week right
so having a sense for everything that
you have to do is only the step one we
also are really concerned about helping
people get an actionable plan to feel
accomplished at the end of the day not
just to do all those tasks but to be
able to have the healthy habits of being
intentional about how you spend your
time to be able to feel like you did
something I'll paint a picture of two
different days this is me a lot of days
maybe it's familiar you start the day
phone in hand trying to figure out
what's up for the day coffee and the
other trying to figure out like Oh
somebody's emailing me I'll follow up on
that when I get to my desk and then
maybe come in try to start a something
so I start a document start a some
something that requires individual
effort go off to another meeting maybe
have some follow-up so you have to take
care of and then come back to a project
and then come back to emails and then
come back to oh and you get chat
messages and then it sort of gets kind
of more of reactive more of a fragmented
set of things that you just have to
react to you throughout the day
I don't end those days feeling very
great about what I do I'm feeling very
accomplished it feels like I'm just
battling things
another type of day one that I would
hope more people could have and I feel
really accomplished at the end of these
days know exactly my goal for the
day right like start the day knowing
what the the meaningful thing is that
you can accomplish the like one two
three three two five whatever tasks that
I there are actually actionable today
and they are going to get done and spend
some focused time on that and then maybe
go off and do the collaborative
exercises to get tasks from other
situations and know that you won't
forget them capture them in a way that
you won't forget them and that you're
gonna follow up on them and then
actually get to you know a different
type of task time a time where you can
just tick off a whole lot of things
right like the micro micro productivity
session that we were in or some of us
were in earlier today you know getting
lots of little things done get that
little energy boost right get a lot of
little things that are very actionable
and require a different type of focus
this kind of day doesn't just come by
accident it comes from intentional
planning and it's hard it's really hard
I was just having dinner earlier this
week with a friend whose kid is going
off to college and he was talking about
how he was struggling with just
developing the like executive
functioning and skills to take a big
project right like a thing I have to do
a huge deadline or something and know
that there are intermediary steps the
the deadline to you know really get
started otherwise I'm in trouble the
deadline to produce the first draft the
the things that I have to do to be able
to accomplish what I need and not be
rushed these are the skills that are
required for planning my day for
estimating the time that something will
take and these are all things that can
be assisted especially with computers
being able to estimate task duration but
it doesn't come in isolation it's hard
to estimate tasks in isolation tasks or
more than tasks they are those things
they come with goals that come with the
the cut the full context of a project
that they relate to and so I want to be
able to support people in those healthy
daily habits those those things where at
the beginning of the day
they can come up with a plan they can
see what the most meaningful things are
for them to focus on today and they
actually have the tools support them in
doing that hello
that's loud hi my name is Shree I work
in being specifically I work in whole
page organization and answers and
entities as we call it in our internal
lingo what it means essentially is I
think from a search standpoint we are
always trying to solve micro tasks as
the word has been used or sometimes that
is d thing you're doing search in many
ways I think we're evolved to the speed
of things and so both sides both the
user and us as a search engine live like
no tomorrow which means the user types
in a small query text to us like whether
and they say give it to me and I'm done
and from our side we're like oh you said
weather okay I just need to give you
something in few milliseconds and that's
it we generally don't either in the
habit of worrying about oh what what we
asked me whether about are you thinking
about what to wear today I you have a
picnic plan like what is the larger
theme that you're asking so in
historically speaking search engines
don't get that much context because
nobody has time to tell all the context
and writing his effort so in general
search has been started that way but
more and more we see it going towards
getting other signals so for example if
you say like Homes for Sale of course
it's a very big test you're not gonna
buy the house online you are been
thinking about data you just heard a
conversation the market is hard you know
buy something soon so what do we do with
this so the sessions are drawn out long
for us like buying a house so we we try
to figure out if what is the first way
we can satisfy that current answer so we
always think in like what is this how
can I give the delight right now
right so if I can bring you a better
experience I can hopefully say okay you
got me a collection of homes
come back tomorrow and then I can
probably find you the next thing here we
try to hook the people in a sense so
once you say I'm looking for homes you
probably are curious about following if
there's new homes coming in the market
god you're tough doesn't end with just
homes so there are these other ways the
engine search engines are now trying to
understand the user better so we can
satisfy them tomorrow better now
something like spider-man you know if
you just search spider-man normally and
he just given the fictional character
everybody knows about it but when you
search today you're probably looking for
the movie that just came out you know so
we need to understand you just had
spider-man I need to understand okay
this is 2019 the movie has been released
there is a movie theater near you it's
four o'clock so better show me shows for
six o'clock or after so all of these
implicit things you just said spider-man
I need to figure all of this out and
give you the best answer at the same
time so from a search standpoint the
tasks are evolving to understand as much
signals as possible and bring together a
better experience that satisfies pretty
much not just oh you got the movie I
don't need a character I already know
the character here is the showtimes near
you here at the top theaters near you
not some random theater
so we are bringing together a better
experience as we've all tasks and to
push further we are also now
understanding the fundamental biases in
queries and you know it biases a very
big thing today in the world of news and
information so when somebody says is
coffee good for me right so I'm really
trying to say give me all the good stuff
about coffee but the reason you type
that query in was you heard something
that there might be something bad about
it so we are trying to now understand
the semantics behind it there why did
you say good for me so we try to bring
both sides now so if you try like in
your phones or laptops its coffee good
for me in Bing you will see both the
good and the bad sides of it and that's
because we are understanding behind why
did you issue the query good and good
has two meanings right and lastly in
terms of like intelligence we have if
you do an enterprise search and I say
like Simon's office right we
historically would just be a web results
coming for I don't know what Simon's
office means today but now because
you're an enterprise you understand that
oh there's a Simon you've been having a
conversation with you're probably
meeting we don't know that but I can
quickly pull up the office a map a
layout exactly point where it is so like
all of these signals implicit are coming
together to push the experience forward
and if you think about it it's all like
adding intelligence and again living
like no tomorrow giving you in a few
milliseconds the answers but kind of
pushing the boundaries of the web or
rather the text box what you gave us in
the text box and advancing it that's
like my brief kind of intro but happy to
talk more so I'll get off to Howard
thank you
[Applause]